another federal appeals court has ruled
against Donald Trump's Muslim ban this
was already the second attempt at the
travel ban you'll remember that the
first version of the travel ban was
defeated in February when it was
declared unconstitutional by a federal
appeals court because it violated the
Establishment cause Clause of the US
Constitution which guarantees freedom of
the religion the administration signed
this new version of the executive order
on March 6th which has slightly looser
provisions just one week later it was
also declared unconstitutional by a US
District Court in Hawaii on May 25th the
federal appeals court in Richmond
Virginia upheld that decision on June
1st the Trump administration appealed
that decision to the Supreme Court and
yesterday in a separate lawsuit the
travel ban was unanimously ruled
unconstitutional by the US Court of
Appeals for the Ninth Circuit in San
Francisco what's fascinating about these
decisions Pat is that the federal
appeals courts have ruled the travel ban
unconstitutional for different reasons
each time the appeals court in Virginia
upheld the unconstitutionality based on
the Establishment Clause violation
before yesterday all rulings against
both versions of the travel ban cited
different combinations of the
Establishment Clause equal protection
and due process this new decision
yesterday from the san francisco u.s.
appeals court said that by signing the
travel ban Donald Trump exceeded the
National Security decision-making power
granted to the president by Congress
judge judge Derek Watson wrote in the
court's opinion quote the order does not
offer a sufficient justification to
suspend the entry of more than 180
million people on the basis of
nationality national security is not a
talismanic incantation that once invoked
can support any and all exercise of
executive power so federal courts are
coming at this from different sides and
they're finding that in multiple
waise Donald Trump's executive order
violates all kinds of constitutional
amendments and statutory laws there's
just no way this is going to fly
yeah and just from a strategic
perspective putting aside the fact that
it's bad policy and it's xenophobic and
all that he should really just raise the
white flag on this one I mean multiple
attempts at the ban multiple reasons for
being struck down and he's undermining
his own lawyers when he calls it a ban
in a tweet when they've been arguing for
months that it's not a ban
well there are people who are arguing
that even if it ultimately fails which
it appears it will that it's still good
for Donald Trump to keep pushing it
because in the eyes of many trumpets he
will have tried he will have stuck to
his promise of trying to do it it's not
his fault that Democrats Obama Hillary
Clinton some dude named Benghazi or
whatever prevented this from happening
or liberal judges activist judges on the
court there might be benefit from Trump
to continuing to push it and having it
the claw rejected by courts I don't know
that could be true if he's all he wants
to do is hold down his base of 35 to 40
percent of people yeah remember when he
announced the Muslim ban as he boarded
it then in December 2015 his poll
numbers actually went up and probably
helped them win a few states and by the
way the timing of that announcement and
of these trial bans I want to remind you
that these were temporary travel bans
for 90 days one part of it a hundred and
twenty days for another part of it Trump
wants to push this to the Supreme Court
the Supreme Court may never hear it by
the time the Supreme Court would hear it
those 90 120 day ban periods would be
over so the Supreme Court would be
hearing something that was only meant to
be temporary to begin with and whose
temporary period would already have a
lapse so on every angle this is just
utter nonsense yeah and probably at this
point I think Kennedy who was often the
deciding vote in the Supreme Court yeah
would side with the Liberals but who
knows if they had another conservative
justice on there maybe they would
support Trump span maybe but haven't we
figured out what the hell is going on
yet I mean Donald Trump said the ban
wasn't the mechanism to figure out
what's going on the ban was going to be
in place so that we could simultaneously
figure out
quote what the hell is going on it was a
sort of pause on immigration while Trump
determined what the hell was going on
it's been almost five months how long is
it going to take to figure out what the
hell is going on I would love to see the
steps that they've taken to find out
what the hell is going on because that
was the solution to the problem this was
just temporary and by the way Trump's
tweets as Pat mentioned earlier are not
going to help him the this decision
actually cited Trump's tweets as part of
the context in which the ban was
presented Brad Jaffe from NBC News
tweeted that part of the decision and
the highlighted portion says here indeed
the president recently confirmed his
assessment that it is the countries that
are inherently dangerous rather than the
hundred and eighty million individual
nationals of those countries who are
barred from entry under the president's
travel ban see at real Donald Trump
Twitter June 52017 6:20 p.m. that's
right we need a travel ban for certain
dangerous countries the tweets are part
of the decision folks so Trump is not
going to be able to get away from those
which is what we suspected but he could
just take the tweets down he could
delete them retro actively because as we
know once you delete something from the
internet it's like it never had on it's
gone it's it might as well never even
think about it so good news because this
travel ban makes no sense and I would
just love the answer ask Sean Spicer hey
Sean what date do you think you'll have
figured out what the hell is going on
join us on our reddit discussion forum
david pakman.com slash our EDD i.t great
interview coming up for you after the
break today's program is made possible
in part by Gamefly which is sort of like
netflix for video games they've got over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can also stream
games you don't even need a gaming
console or a computer because you can
stream games through your Amazon fire
stick or roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
30-day free trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30 day trial for
David Pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at Gamefly
offer.com forward slash TDP s